we'd already had the headline scottish
cricket is further damned by the detail
a review found that of 31 tests for
institutional racism qriket scotland
failed on 29
it didn't surprise the two players who
prompted the review
kasim sheikh and majid hack welcomed the
report's findings and spoke of a sport
shamed by white privilege there's time
for change now not tomorrow not in a
couple of months not a few months time i
keep hearing it's going to take time
it's going to take time and racism
always seems to be at the at the back of
the back of the line i want to see it be
at the front now as has been highlighted
by plan for sporting their review qriket
scotland have been found to be
institutionally racist so i think it's
time now
for change
the review heard complaints of racism in
cricket of discrimination and of what it
called persistent microaggressions based
on rape
referrals have been made to the police
as possible hate crimes
the cricket scotland board had stepped
down the day before the report's
publication leaving the interim chief
executive to speak on its behalf we have
apologized to everybody who's
experienced racism will you apologize
directly to magitek and kasim sheikh i
am hoping to meet with them both in the
very near future will you apologize to
them and it's really important that we
let the process that will review their
situation
we've heard words of comfort and they
are comforting words as we stand here
today
the word they want to hear directly from
you as the chief executive of qriket
scotland is sorry will you say sorry to
them look i'm sorry for everything
that's happened to everybody involved in
this whole process
an apology denied in one interview
didn't go down well in another a general
apology is just too generic it's very
easy so i think everyone who's taken
part in this and who've suffered
racism they should be contacted
individually so it's really important
cricket's gone are starting a clean
slate so for me that was a that's been a
bit of a blunder from the new ceo there
the review found a lack of anti-racist
training at qriket scotland and a lack
of diversity throughout the game
structure
among the recommendations was for a new
board with a greater male female balance
and with a quarter of its makeup from
non-white backgrounds
it is a sport on the verge of change in
scotland cricket is relatively low
profile
but it's now home to a scandal that's
anything but
james matthews sky news sterling